♪ SHOWER THE PEOPLE YOU LOVE WITH LOVE  ♪
♪ SHOW THEM THE WAY THAT YOU FEEL ♪
♪
LIVE LONG LIKE HE WOULD, BIG
SMILES.
BIG HEART.
BIG SERVICE, ALL LOVE.
OFFICER SEAN COLLIER WE LOVE
YOU.
THE INSTITUTE CONVENED A
COMMITTEE TO THINK ABOUT A
MEMORIAL FOR SEAN COLLIER.
THE FIGURE OF THE MEMORIAL IS A
KIND OF FIVE-WALL STRUCTURE
EXTRUDED.
AND THEN A VOID IS ACTUALLY
CARVED OUT OF IT.
AND THAT VOID REPRESENTS A KIND
OF ABSENCE OR LOSS.
THE FORM ITSELF IS BASED ON THE
HAND REPRESENTING BOTH A KIND OF
GESTURE OF OPENNESS TO OTHERS.
BUT ALSO THE ABILITY TO APPLY
ONE'S SELF TO MAKE THINGS
BETTER.
WE WANTED THE STONE TO BE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE PLACES
WHERE SEAN SPENT A LOT OF TIME,
LIKE THE MIT OUTING CLUB, SO WE
THOUGHT OF GRANITE, NEW
HAMPSHIRE.
THE MEMORIAL IS MADE OF 32
BLOCKS WHICH PIECE TOGETHER IN A
WAY THAT ALLOWS EACH BLOCK TO
HOLD THE OTHER ONE UP.
I WILL GO AROUND AND GET THE
OTHER TWO.
SO IT'S STRENGTH COMES FROM
UNITY.
ITS STRENGTH COMES FROM THE
MANY, AS OPPOSED TO A SINGULAR
GESTURE.
SO HERE IT'S 90 AND A HALF
AND HERE IS 91 AND A HALF
PEOPLE DON'T BUILD ANYMORE
THIS WAY.
SO IT'S AN EXPERIMENT IN USING
REALLY OLD-FASHIONED TECHNIQUES
OF STONE MASONRY.
SORT OF PRE-MODERN BUT USING
HIGH-END COMPUTERS TO DETERMINE
SHAPES AND LAY-OUT OF THE
STONES.
WE ARE SAYING THIS IS A-1,
IT'S GREAT, IT'S PERFECT.
THE FIVE WALLS ACTUALLY
EXTEND OUT FROM THE CENTER VOID
AS THEY EXTEND OUT THEY FRAME
VERY SPECIFIC VIEWS.
THE TWO WALLS CLOSEST
TOGETHER ALIGN WITH A LOCATION
OF SEAN'S CRUISER WHERE HE WAS
SHOT.
IT'S THE MOST INTIMATE SPACE IN
THE MEMORIAL.
WHEN YOU WERE UNDER IT FRAMES
EXACTLY THAT SPOT WHERE THE
TRAGEDY OCCURRED.
WHAT WE REALLY HAVE IS FIVE
HALF ARCHES EACH LEANING IN
TOWARDS THE MIDDLE.
WHILE THAT HALF ARCH SHOULD FALL
OVER, THERE IS ANOTHER HALF ARCH
SOMEWHERE ELSE LEANING IN AND
ANOTHER HALF ARCH, EACH ARE
COMING TOGETHER, AND BALANCING, IN THE MIDDLE.
SO THE ARCH IS EXERTING AN OUTWARD FORCE
AND THE FIVE WALLS ARE A
BUTTRESSING THE CENTER PART OF A
VERY FLAT VAULT.
AS THE ARCHES PUSH OUT WARDS ON
THE WALLS, THE WALLS WANT TO
SPREAD OUT, AND BURIED
UNDERGROUND IS A TENSION TIE
WHICH IS PULLING TOWARDS THE CENTER AND
PULLING THE WHOLE MEMORIAL
TOGETHER SO IT'S AN EQUILIBRIUM.
BELOW GROUND THERE IS A GRADE BEAM WHICH IS POURED IN CONCRETE
AND IT'S REINFORCED CONCRETE SO THERE IS STEEL EMBEDDED IN
WHICH CARRIES THE TENSILE FORCES
TO ENSURE THAT THE
WALLS WILL NOT MOVE OUTWARD OVER
THE CENTURIES.
THE OUTSIDE OF THE SCULPTURE
IS ALL GOING TO BE A FLAMED FINISH.
THIS IS A FINE GRAIN AND DENSE
GRANITE, BUT LEAVES A FLAT BUT
A MORE NATURAL TEXTURED SURFACE.
EACH STONE IS CUT WITH
ADVANCED MILLING TECHNOLOGY AND
SOME STONES ARE CUT BY ROBOTS.
AND THE ACCURACY OF EACH STONE
IS WITHIN ONE MILLIMETER.
EVEN AS THE ROBOT IS CARVING
THE BLOCKS, SOMEONE HAS TO TAP
EVERY SINGLE PIECE AND BREAK IT
OFF ONE BY ONE, BEFORE THE ROBOT
CAN COME IN FOR ITS FINAL PASS.
IT WAS A KIND OF INCREDIBLE
DANCE BETWEEN LIKE MACHINE AND
MAN TO CARVE THESE PIECES.
IT'S LIKE A THREE-DIMENSIONAL
JIGSAW PUZZLE WITH FINELY
POLISHED BLOCKS OF GRANITE.
BUT IN THIS CASE THEY WEIGH ABOUT 10,000 POUNDS EACH.
MY NAME IS ROB ROGERS, A PROJECT
MANAGER FOR SUFFOLK CONSTRUCTION
AND I'M ALSO SEAN COLLIER'S BROTHER.
THERE IS A SEQUENCE OF HOW WE ARE GOING TO LOWER THE STONES.
SO, IN THEORY, THE STONES SHOULD LOCK IN PLACE.
WHEN THE FIRST BLOCKS ARRIVED
AND STARTED TO TAKE PHYSICAL
FORM, AS AN ARCHITECT THAT'S THE
MAGICAL MOMENT.
WHEN A CONCEPT TURNS INTO
PHYSICAL REALITY.
THERE WERE MANY TIMES IN THIS
WHOLE PROJECT WHERE WE HAD TO
KEEP OUR EMOTIONS IN CHECK.
BECAUSE IT WAS SUCH AN
EMOTIONAL PROJECT FOR EVERYONE INVOLVED
IT'S BEEN VERY HUMBLING AND HEALING, YOU KNOW, IN THE PAST
ALMOST TWO YEARS SINCE SEAN IS
GONE.
IT'S HELPED A LOT.
WE STARTED WITH THE KEYSTONE
AND WE HAD TO BUILD A TEMPORARY
SCAFFOLD UNDER THAT KEYSTONE AND
THEN THE RING STONES CAME IN
NEXT, AND WE SEQUENTIALLY WENT
THROUGH EACH OF THE FIVE LEGS.
THIS HAS PROBABLY BEEN THE HARDEST
SEASON TO BUILD IN.
WE HAVE 109 INCHES, WORSE
WINTER EVER IN BOSTON.
IT MADE THINGS MORE CHALLENGING.
BUT EVERYONE ON SITE WAS GREAT.
WE KNEW WE HAD AN END DATE AND
WE NEED TO MEET THIS DATE.
SO GUYS WORKED HARDER AND
LONGER.
THE MOST EXCITING MOMENT AND
THE MOST CRITICAL MOMENT IN THE
CONSTRUCTION IS WHEN WE LOWER
THE SCAFFOLDING AND THE WEIGHT OF THE KEYSTONE
AND THE VAULT GO INTO THE FIVE
WALLS FOR THE FIRST TIME.
WE HAVE INSTRUMENTS FOR
DISPLACEMENTS IN 25 DIFFERENT LOCATIONS
AND THEN WE HAVE GOT 9 SCALES
UNDERNEATH IT
TAKING LOAD READINGS
SO WE ARE GOING TO BE DOING REAL-TIME MEASUREMENTS
OF HOW THE LOAD IS BEING TRANSFERRED.
WE WILL START WITH THE FOUR
MIDDLE ONES.
AS WE LOWER THE TEMPORARY
SUPPORTS AND THEY COME DOWN, THE
LOAD ON THE SCALE SHOULD COME
DOWN.
AND THE LOAD ON THE SCALES WILL BE
GOING DOWN BECAUSE THE WEIGHT OF
THE STONES ARE GOING ON ARCHING.
IF WE LOWER THE SUPPORTS AND THE
READING ON THE SCALE DOESN'T
CHANGE, THAT'S BAD.
ONE
TWO
THREE.
WOW, BABY.
THAT'S GREAT.
[APPLAUSE]
SO BEHIND "B" LEG IS A LITTLE
PART OF MY SPEECH THAT I GAVE
FOR SEAN.
SO THEY ENGRAVED IT ON TO THE
STONE.
SO LIVE LONG LIKE HE WOULD, BIG
HEARTS AND BIG SMILES AND BIG
SERVICE, ALL LOVE.
HE WAS A JUST KID THAT LOVED BEING A COP, AND HAD A MILLION FRIENDS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW HE SLEPT,
ALWAYS DOING SOMETHING AND
HANGING OUT WITH SOMEBODY.
REALLY LIVED LIFE TO ITS
FULLEST.
♪ SHOWER THE PEOPLE YOU LOVE WITH LOVE ♪
HE WAS MADE TO BE A POLICE
OFFICER, I KNOW THAT HIS MOTHER
SAID THAT HE WANTED TO BE A
POLICEMEN FROM THE TIME HE WAS
SEVEN YEARS OLD.
AND IT SHOWED, IT SHOWED IN
EVERYTHING HE DID, HE GOT IT.
IT'S A VERY OPEN STRUCTURE
FOR SOMETHING BUILT OUT OF SUCH
SOLID STONE, AND IT'S TO BE A
GATEWAY INTO CAMPUS.
THERE'S PEOPLE MILLING AROUND, THEY SPEND A LOT OF TIME IN NORTH COURT,
THEY LIKE TO BE OUTSIDE
SO WE HAVE THESE BENCHES AND
THERE WILL BE TREES.
AND IT HOPEFULLY WILL BE A PLACE
THAT WE WILL ENJOY SITTING DOWN AND
SPENDING TIME WITH THEIR FRIENDS
AND THE COMMUNITY.
I HOPE THAT THE MEMORIAL WILL
BECOME ONE OF THE BELOVED
ELEMENTS ON CAMPUS.
HOPEFULLY IT CAN REMAIN FOR US
TO REMEMBER SEAN'S SERVICE AND
THE COMING TOGETHER OF THE
COMMUNITY.
AND OUR VALUES.